what's your favorite type of dog hi I'm
do I'm a girl who deserves all the
luxury money can buy I love listening to
classical music and being outdoors hello
I'm Jay I'm a 10 year old and I came to
Battersea after my own and started
working longer hours I like the quiet
and looking for a peaceful home where I
can relax hmm hey I'm yogi I am a sweet
boy and a laugh to be around okey-dokey
hi I'm Cody I'm a chihuahua cross pug
this one okay how important is it for
people to adopt abandoned dogs like me
extremely supportive actually supposed
to say he's gonna go home to a kennel
tonight again and he really should be
going home to your family not that they
are learning it from the back seat yeah
it's not dogs there right Cody who is
your favorite on-screen dog don't save a
see my favorite on-screen dog is this
hobo when I was kid white Jay here you
go Danny
oh yeah what's your favorite type of dog
actually any dumpers really he's just
got have a big heart and my stubs do so
look so dazed look at this winning might
point out Paul on pizza yes or no yet I
think it can be to be fair it's a good
question
Thanks
have you ever been in the metaphorical
doghouse before if so why yes you miss
caters to many - - to give you all my
know you put your bunghole this way mate
and face that way down the lens your
Prime Minister for the day
what new law would you make yeah
responsibility of being a prime minister
for the rain it would be nice to have a
really good woman someday maybe sit down
six-six-six 666 666 he struggles to find
the truth and in doing so he breaks eggs
doing that and upsetting people that he
loves so it's not really that honest and
he has to come to terms with his honesty
by getting infected by a huge alien
lives inside him can it all goes a bit
horribly wrong for him and it turns out
they can live together he can live with
this OD and it runs around in his body
rent-free does that make any sense not
remotely it just isn't it
[Music]
you